flying robots and CIA agents Jack a man
in his 20s diagnosed with schizophrenia
paste the streets he heard buzzing which
he attributed to a tacky robots he swung
his body around in defense he was
convinced CIA agents lurked in the
bushes and so he looked around
suspiciously he was completely alone in
this world of imaginary intruders yet he
was surrounded by real people Jack had
not seen a psychiatrist in weeks and he
was off his medications leaving him
agitated and paranoid like so many times
in the past someone became fearful and
called the police Jack was arrested for
disturbing the peace and he was brought
to the hospital as a medical student I
first met Jack in the locked ward where
he's being held for treatment as part of
the medical team I worked to change his
medications to better control the
psychosis to make those attacking robots
and CIA agents disappear his stay in the
hospital was obviously meant to be
therapeutic but while he was with us he
missed several probation hearings for
past offenses he lost access to
low-income housing and he was kept out
of the workforce Jack's story is all too
emblematic of those with serious mental
illness in the United States it is a
story characterized by inadequate
solutions broken systems and the need
for something more something additional
with the capacity to heal serious mental
illness though is not limited to
schizophrenia it includes any mental
illness that causes significant
impairment and daily like a life
activities like working it includes the
brother with severe anxiety the
grandfather with PTSD and the mother
with bipolar disorder think of those in
your life who have struggled with mental
illness there
alone there are 44 million American
adults with mental illness 44 million
that's more than the population of
California and there are 10 million
American adults with serious mental
illness more than the population of New
York City these statistics include my
own family growing up I watched loved
ones battle mental illness I remember
sitting in folding chairs at Alcoholics
Anonymous meetings listening to poignant
stories of relapse and recovery I
remember patiently waiting for the
visiting hours to begin at the
residential Center for substance abuse
as much as I wanted to help I was a kid
granted I was a scrappy kid I was still
a kid who had enough trouble talking to
girls or choosing a username for AOL
instant messenger a massive massive
challenge and so clearly I was limited
in what i could do these experiences
this feeling of helplessness spark my
initial interest in mental illness and
medicine I became convinced if I wanted
to help those with serious mental
illness like Jack if I wanted to be a
resource to my family I needed to become
a doctor full disclosure I also thought
the doctors on ER were badass
so I had mixed motives but I convinced
Stanford to take me in and I immediately
started looking for opportunities to get
involved I joined a research team that
studies early childhood trauma and
design psychiatric services for
low-income communities I manage the
mental health clinic for adults without
insurance these experiences deep in my
resolve to address mental illness but
they also gave me insight into the very
real constraints of my chosen field it's
true i met doctors who treated patients
with compassion and skill but just a
fraction of those who needed treatment
got it and often after waiting a long
time and as with other diseases it's
really tough to monitor because patients
are rarely in the clinic i also got
exposure to the role of government i'm
at a bunch of patients who went months
if not years with no treatment who
finally got connected to doctors thanks
to government programs and clinics the
reality though is these efforts are
totally insufficient I gradually came to
this realization but it was my
experience with Jack that really
crystallized it I recognize that Jack
needed more than what healthcare and
government could offer to lead a
healthier fuller life Jack needed an
additional a lie so what do you do in
the case of serious mental illness when
healthcare and government fall short I
decided to apply to business school it
was either this or management consulting
ANCA made the right decision but after
spending many years in the Bay Area I
really grew an appreciation for the
ability of business to create products
and solutions for unmet needs and I saw
tremendous potential for its application
to serious mental illness I came to the
conclusion that is business leaders we
are uniquely positioned to tackle the
problems made it visible by Jack story
every day we see all around us how
business can grow economies build
personal fortune and transform the world
I argue business also has the capacity
to heal since starting business school
I've come across the number of companies
in the bay area that are working on
mental illness I'm here today not
talking to you as an entrepreneur and
investor or an employee but rather as a
family member and as a future doctor I
want to share just two companies that
have developed products that are
enabling physicians to better treat
those with serious mental illness these
products are not yet widely available
but they offer a glimpse into the
potential of business its potential in
its capacity to heal Jack's illness is
not static we met him in the hospital
but he can go long stretches of time in
the community doing just fine but when
he has a psychotic break his
schizophrenia is totally debilitating
each episode sets him further and
further back and intervening early is
tough ginger io might offer a solution
it's a mobile app that collects data on
a patient's mobility communication and
sleep patterns with this information as
Jack's doctor I could know when his
behavior is making a major departure
from his normal routine ginger io would
enable me to anticipate Jack psychotic
breaks and to intervene before
hospitalization I'd be the first one to
tell you that Jack's medications are not
perfect but he functions and he feels a
lot better when he takes them but he's
just like the rest of us he often
forgets to take his medications Proteus
digital health the second company is
working to improve medication adherence
it is developed a tiny ingestible sensor
that fits inside individual pills when
you take the pill it's activated by the
fluids in your stomach and a signal is
sent to a patch on your skin that
pageant turn communicates with a
smartphone which collects data on
medication adherence it's pretty cool
right
yeah it is stay with me with Proteus as
Jack's doctor I could know when he is
off his medications and I could help him
reach his goal of leading a healthier
life imagine what future solutions could
be designed if more business leaders
like us applied our creativity in our
acumen toward serious mental illness
imagine how Jack's life could be
different if you had access to ginger
i/o and proteus and now take that impact
and multiply it by the 10 million other
American adults with serious mental
illness in this way business has the
capacity to heal our inadequate response
to serious mental illness is a glaring
example of our collective failure to
serve some of the weakest members in our
society while this failure is largely
hidden mental illness touches all of our
lives business and technology are not
perfect solutions but they have
incredible potential to help as business
leaders we have the ability to transform
what is today to what can be tomorrow my
journey which now includes medicine and
business is still uncharted as is yours
as you leave today and as you look to
your own future I simply ask you to be
more inclusive to include Jack as you go
out to reshape the world thank you
you